the introduction to Big Data and life
sciences is a 15 day online program
developed by pine biotech in this
program participants will learn about
the impact of the genomic revolution
next-generation sequencing and
computational technologies in every area
of life sciences including research
biomedical biotechnology and agro
biology here you will learn to find
understand and then analyze data using
high-performance computing as well as
user-friendly tools for biologists
sessions will be held online and on-site
at the biologic support services in
Lagos Nigeria the program is designed
for students and faculty from life
sciences backgrounds in this program we
will speak about big data how it is
transformed the life sciences as well as
introduced both challenges and
opportunities into every aspect of
research biomedical discovery
biotechnology as well as agriculture the
speakers and trainers in this program
have ample experience in both academia
and industry together they will help
illustrate the significance of
bioinformatics in every aspect of life
science research as well as show how
this discipline can and should become a
skill set mastered by every student
researcher and faculty member the
program will be held online with
one-hour online sessions as well as
self-paced materials that are available
for access online throughout our
project-based educational portal the
program will start on March 2nd 2020 and
six online sessions we will cover many
of the introductory materials that will
be important for anyone interested in
bioinformatics data science experimental
design and research using onyx
technologies we will start with an
overview of omics data and the
significance of the technologies
generating it we will speak about the
next-generation sequencing process and
how it influences the methods of
analysis to
analyze as well as interpret the
molecular level of information this data
yields the discovery of the structure of
DNA had a profound effect on my ability
to study the genetic code however it
took almost 50 years from that time the
sequence the first human genome
soon after the technology developed at
that time evolved rapidly by 2015 the
1000 genome project brought a
significant number of whole genome
sequences to the research community and
in 2008 over 100,000 whole genomes were
sequenced today there is an ever
increasing number of genomic
transcriptomics proteomics and medicine
ah McDade assets available that describe
subcellular processes with highly
detailed digital data after learning
about the history of omics data and its
availability we will speak about the
challenges as well as opportunities such
data has brought to life sciences
research to illustrate the challenges
and opportunities we will review
examples of projects as well as data
types one can find on public domain
repositories that are ready for analysis
this introductory course will provide a
review of multiple online resources
courses and projects that can serve as a
springboard into the world of
bioinformatics the projects include
genomic transcript dominic made a
genomic and epigenomic data types that
you can learn from and you can even
develop a project of your own in the
next session we will look at some of the
information each one of these data types
contains such a single nucleotide
variation gene expression and even the
composition of microbial samples to
understand how these data types are
processed analyzed as well as visualized
we review the major steps involved in
the analysis of NGS data omics
technologies are becoming cheaper and
are used to explore the roles
relationships and actions of the various
types of molecules that make up the
cells of an organism of omics data can
be generated using NGS or what is also
known as high-throughput sequencing
the data can show detailed information
about genomic variants epigenomic
regulation as well as gene and isoform
expression in the next session we will
spend some time speaking about methods
of analysis as well as computational
approaches that can automate the
statistical test we used to find
patterns in this oftentimes noisy and
complex data some of the technologies we
will learn to apply are easy even for
the bioinformatics novice and can be
done in Excel or any other type of table
manipulation software others require a
basic understanding of our libraries as
well as how to deploy those in our
studio we will also discuss more
streamline approaches using the
analytical T - bio info platform that we
will be using throughout this course
however the growing amount of
variability in the data requires
advanced data mining as well as machine
learning that can be sensitive to
complexity and yet extract meaningful
patterns in huge datasets these
approaches are regularly used in
impactful publications so we review
major types of methods and then attempt
to apply them to several examples from
public domain repositories we will learn
about clustering dimensionality
reduction as well as classification and
the impact of feature selection on
interpretation of a condition that is
sampled from various datasets finally we
will discuss the biology one can find in
these datasets how to leverage reference
databases as well as annotate found
patterns by linking objects to genes
pathways and gene ontology terms or look
for variation between groups and then
test for cause-and-effect relationships
and the data to illustrate these
approaches we will learn to utilize gene
set enrichment analysis to find pathways
or gene sets that are enriched with up
or down regulated genes of interests
this program will be an excellent
introduction to the resources materials
and a vibrant online community you can
join to continue learning about
bioinformatics specifically you will get
to experience bioinformatics for
yourself and try The Fault
find and understand NGS data what is the
data set or project about what is the
question you are trying to ask and can
your data answer the question you will
process data perform quality control map
and align then quantify and evaluate
pipeline outputs next you will analyze
data by learning about the statistical
approaches as well as exploratory data
analysis you will then interpret your
data by annotation using reference
databases and pathway analysis
penultimately
you will consider an independent project
and have the opportunity to learn more
from futurama slogic programs online
lastly participants will learn about
student and faculty resources to make
bioinformatics more accessible in Africa
you can review the materials and
projects we use on edu T - bio info and
request a demo account on the T - bio
info big data analytical platform for
bioinformatics analysis the program is
now open for registration and will come
with a certificate of participation for
those who have completed the
requirements for this program we welcome
you to reach out to us with any
questions as well share this
informational video with your colleagues
and friends the program is designed for
biologists clinicians and researchers or
students that are interested in
advancing their understanding of big
data and life sciences the program will
not require any background in coding
bioinformatics or biostatistics
however we will speak about topics
related to cell and molecular biology
and utilize terminology coming from
biostatistics as well as data science
domains anyone with a good handle on
Biological Sciences at an undergraduate
University level is welcome to join